reste un oh mes halètements ala dos saloon d'El
apostolat sur l'acteur d'illusion de cobalt
Amica haveli passe la fièvre fais du beau
travail Tonto tension à Apogee Dodi Valley
donc Nouveau film au total voiture iguazu en
zone 8 XP zone clé dans un madaba convoité
aussi don '  t rester en vie
Joséphine était une image de mod très complète
camasta Festus métamorphoser c'était très
difficile mais exactement comment cela s'est produit est
quelque chose comme ça nous avons travaillé nous étions 21
semaines six jours par semaine au début
les cinq premières semaines étaient cinq heures par
jour trois heures  danser deux heures d'
haltérophilie et après cinq semaines
c'était peut-être huit heures de danse et
peut-être trois heures d'haltérophilie et
puis juste avant le début du film
c'était parfois 14 heures par jour avec l'
exercice donc c'était très difficile mais dans
le régime était très strict
riche en protéines le Poisson place une
ambiance deux saisons Maceo sylvester
stallone propose un Vig continue à l'
opposé l'image médiévale bien j'ai
vu j'ai vu le film rock III et le
style du film m'a beaucoup impressionné je
l'ai trouvé fantastique et j'ai dit si  J'ai
déjà fait la suite de Saturne et de la fièvre en
restant en vie sur le point d'avoir sylvester
stallone car le réalisateur serait
incroyable être parfait alors je lui ai demandé
et à ma grande surprise il a dit oui donc j'étais
très heureux et nous avons très bien travaillé
ensemble John Travolta Alberta a bu
moyen ou même très nerveux
Parapet tunisien coma échantillon six eh bien non
pas vraiment parce que je pense à moi et
je pense que la plupart du public pense que
je suis d'abord un acteur mais une partie du
package d'être un acteur est et
disons un  l'acteur célèbre serait aussi un
sex-symbol
donc ça va parce que c'est nécessaire
je pense que la maladie le lanthane il est bon